hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong I am back it's
your girl Jacqueline alongside my
co-host Mr Mark Ellis I missed you sir
welcome back your dreams were your
ticket out you went to France you went
to Texas you went all over the globe jet
setting and Rome so you're covering
movies you're at festivals you did all
the things and now you're back here back
here and honestly it's it's good because
I felt like my absence it was feeling a
bit devious a bit Insidious you felt wow
I just felt and you set up our mind to
not be here but since we are back we're
going to be talking horror that's right
we're going to be talking about
Insidious chapter two and alongside us
today we have a great host he is a video
Creator on Tick Tock he's also the host
of House of Cinema podcast lover of
movies literatures in a very
controversial talk to a topic we'll get
to later Cinema Joe sir welcome to the
Pod thank you for having me happy happy
to be here is it controversial I cannot
believe this is controversial but so I
can't wait to hear more about this
opinion because we kind of dusted it
before we went to air yeah and I know a
little bit of the back story but
Jacqueline you you were in deep in the
trenches when this sort of came when
this this movie that has caused some of
this controversy yes had come out so
this is what it is so Rotten Tomatoes
people they have as you all know
listening and watching they have y'all
have feelings you'll have opinions and
you get open your feelings about it and
one of the things was the highest ranked
movie on Rotten Tomatoes we have a list
on the tomatoes on the Tomato Meter and
for the longest time it was citizen King
and then our archives Tim Ryan who we'll
talk to later his team so blame him went
and discovered a contemporary review of
Citizen Kane that trashed it because
people don't remember Citizen Kane was
actually not very well received it was
two avant-garde for its time didn't win
the Oscars
[Applause]
thank you Mr Snowdon just saying that
you forget things but that's what I
remember uh so when it went off
Paddington 2 became the highest ranked
movie and like that was like a whole
nother thing because the Paddington two
people were so excited until lo and
behold we found another review and then
Paddington 2 got dethroned and then the
Paddington two people started flooding
my inbox and DMS with what did you do
and so so when you do a joke yeah he was
saying are you one of these people no no
no no no I was not in the DM okay uh
well it was like was I spearheading the
movement to kind of bring back
Paddington to the Forefront number one
spot above Citizen Kane I may have been
there oh my God
pro Paddington two
uh I want to say I'm anti-assistance you
hate Citizen Kane why but I mean Orson
Wells is just rolling over in his grace
could maybe juices and Kane but person
Wells do Paddington 2 is the real
question I think the real thing we need
ask ourselves is in maybe 30 years from
now can we see Paddington do ads for
ripple line
maybe absolutely honestly I was thinking
about the guy that voices Paddington too
and you were saying that and I was just
picturing him because I always forget
what he looks like and then I was like
wait a minute who voices him and then I
thought of his face he's the guy he's
such a he plays creeps on TV but he has
like the most Angelic voice
yeah
and he also is in um this may hurt where
he plays like a really like Angry nurse
and so I was literally I'm like that's
Paddington
it's a great it's a great gig the bear
is adorable I love Paddington too but
you know Citizen Kane's up there too
would you pick
I I would go Citizen Kane for the
history of it um because I enjoyed my
time here but oh my gosh I feel like
Paddington too at least was able to like
springboard off of the first Paddington
where Citizen Kane just had to like
conjure itself out of nothing
um a lot like Insidious two yeah got to
rely on the lore of the first Insidious
which was a monster hit as was the
second one I think the second one on a
budget of maybe what five six million
dollars made like over 150 million
dollars at the box office but it's still
just that first Insidious movie that is
fresh and and it's it's fresh so I'm not
gonna knock it but it's 66 fresh so
you're in Freshfield but you're not
exactly in the nicest part of town yeah
let's take a trip out because uh in uh
Insidious Chapter 2 is 2013. so this was
like the Heyday of what we would Now
call the found footage era of four this
is a very different time so let's take a
trip back it's Insidious chapter two
it's 38 rotten with a 58 57 run audience
score so even the audience is kind of
mixed on this one we're talking about it
because Insidious Red Door this is now
the fifth installment will be out July
7th and this is a direct sequel to this
installment so for folks that maybe
haven't seen it we have a ton of
editorial on there including all of the
Blum House horror ranked if you want to
check that out I'll just ask you Joe
like what's your just real quick history
with the Insidious franchise how deep
were you into it was this like your fave
I I was a huge Insidious fan when it
came out I saw it in theaters I was uh
with a bunch of friends it was a big
deal I mean cam kind of came out of
nowhere it felt like I mean this one was
earlier in Juan's career so we knew who
James won kind of was you know via saw
but uh I I went in pretty blind and I
thought it was tremendously horrifying
great I had a good time watching it so
then Insidious Chapter 2 comes out uh
was all in all in all my chips are in on
this at this point
um we'll get into more about our
feelings on the cities too but as the
franchise progressed it has gone in an
interesting Direction considering this
is kind of like weirdly parallels The
Conjuring movies which are also coming
out that's around the same time
um but Insidious kind of Falls I don't
want to say falls on the Wayside but it
starts to live in the shadow of The
Conjuring series
um but I've always been a big Insidious
fan I don't know how you guys feel about
it well we'll get to that one before
that though I want Mark to do the great
awesomeness because you're really gonna
have to give a synopsis of Insidious one
and two to give it a synopsis but if you
can please sir let us know what happens
in Insidious chapter two all right so
some spoilers especially for the first
Insidious because the end of the first
Insidious leave software oh thank God we
got out of that one all right
everybody's okay let's have a nice uh
let's have a nice evening and we solve
the thing oh but we didn't though
because Patrick Wilson at the end you
see a photograph and it looks like he's
the one that actually strangled Lynn
Shay's character release at the end of
the first movie so now we open the
second movie and we're investigating who
strangled her we know that it was
somebody taking over Patrick Wilson's
body we don't really know what was
happening it turns out that the
fingerprints on her neck are not Patrick
Wilson's more on that later and so we're
cleared but there's a lot of strange
crap going on in the houses that we
inhabit and it doesn't necessarily be
the houses that are haunted so much as
the people that are inhabiting them
having some demons that they have to
reconcile and so now Patrick Wilson is
sort of fighting for his life as the
rest of the family's thinking do we
leave this guy do we just pack up the
stuff and go and it's not that easy
because one of the kids is starting to
now talk to the other side that we refer
to as the further in this film series
and so we basically have to go on a
mission into the further we meet some
old friends there and we come back out
on the other side but are we better for
the experience or do we disinfect more
people with this thing that now you know
there's an afterlife and you know
there's a lot of other crazy stuff going
on all predicated on this one like
really murderous entity that is appears
to be a woman who looks like the woman
who comes into my room occasionally at
night because I have that sleep what's
the sleep sleep paralysis I'm telling
you it's the same lady she comes in
she's she's past middle age but I
wouldn't call her Elder leagues I don't
want to offend her because again she's
in my room half the time she walks in
like a black dress and she just lays on
top of me just puts a lot of pressure on
my chest this hadn't happened in a
minute but it used to happen a lot and
uh like around the time Insidious came
out I think I found the connection now I
think about it baby I saw these movies
way too many times but yeah she like
puts pressure on you and people who have
sleep paralysis will say like no it's
the same it's the same person coming in
and she's like the evil Santa Claus so
she comes in she puts a lot of pressure
on you and it's that like weird like
you're in between sleep and awake and
you want to fight it it's like like when
you're up at bat and the pitch is coming
and you want to swing at the fastball
you just can't for some reason that's
how it feels so it takes like a good 30
seconds to like get her the hell out of
your room then you wake up and you're
fine but yeah anyway that's the person
in Insidious
that was uh so that's a way to describe
the movie yeah yeah a really personal
journey I took on this one again I
haven't seen her in a minute and I think
my herbal medication real yeah like you
really see a person sleep paralysis she
walks into the room
just kind of floats in lays on top of
you very pushy broad we're talking here
okay I just want to make sure because
like I literally thought that you were
actually saying that you felt a presence
I was like do we need to go into your
ghost I think he is saying that it's not
a ghost
it's just the feeling
I thought you were saying an actual
person
okay yeah and the first time it happened
I thought it was it was a ghost okay
like you were telling that so
convincingly I'm like
uh if I'm sleeping on my back all night
it might happen again so I I'm a side
sleeper okay well that makes good I have
a guard dog now yeah Molly takes care of
her oh my God honestly I literally was
like Wow Mark uh your house is haunted
you should move well according to
Insidious rules moving doesn't help no
this is true we're gonna get it we're
gonna get into that
Joe delivered that line exactly like uh
specs and who's the other guy oh my God
don't do that to him because they're my
biggest beef with this but let's start
with let's start with you wow okay we'll
talk about it Joe sir let's go ahead and
talk about this one is Rotten Tomatoes
right or wrong about Insidious
especially on the on the Tomato Meter
with the 38 38 on the critic side is
Rotten Tomatoes wrong or right in the
long run
I'm gonna say Rotten Tomatoes is right
okay
oh like 38 maybe you push it to 45 but I
don't think this is entering uh fresh
territory for me I think this is a
pretty big
step down from the first Insidious if
I'm being completely honest especially
because the city has it you know really
introduces a lot of interesting Concepts
uh villains I mean we've kind of talked
about this before the podcast started
recording yeah we're gonna get into that
movie talk but you're saying you're
saying it's writing I think it's
right-ish I think it's reddish yes man
do I have to um am I going to be this
girl today what are you going well I I
sort of agree with Joe and that I was
expecting uh certain other entities
slash characters to pop out and then it
never sort of did so I was left feeling
a little flat but I counter that with I
like the way that they expanded some of
the mythology in this world and so I
it's not as good as the first Insidious
I didn't think the scares were as potent
in this one but I would get it just on
the border maybe on the other side of
fresh fill so whereas the first
Insidious is like just limping into
fresh territory I think this one I would
put it around I think Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong but I would put it 55 56 57 I
don't think I would get at that I do
think Rotten Tomatoes wrong you know
what's really weird whatever the score
is again it gets in that 43 range which
gets me on my movie that I have a hard
time with but the one thing I will say
about this I know Insidious is a better
movie than 38 I think I would have to
honestly see it in a different light
than I saw at this time for me to say
where that is because I'm also looking
at this from like 20 23 eyes where like
things don't look as clean as they did
in 2013 like some of the props and some
of the other stuff it just it doesn't I
know I liked that a lot better back then
than I do now are you comparing this to
all the Fancy Pants movies you saw at
Camp no I'm comparing it to like
malignants I'm comparing it to you know
uh some of these more recent horror
movies that were on streaming services
that look better than this one and this
was a theatrical so that's not fair to
the movie but it's like I don't know
where the number is now anyway that's
where I'm saying I will say Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong but I can't like give
you a number if I had to I would say 42.
it's no Paddington too we can all agree
um I definitely I could get it up to a
40 maybe even a 50 but not 55. so anyway
let's go ahead right now and see what
the critics were saying back then let's
listen to my favorite segment two
minutes with Tim
[Music]
director James Juan and writer Lee
winnell cut their teeth not literally on
the saw films so their 2010 movie
Insidious was something of an about face
A Haunted House story that was Moody and
Atmospheric rather than Ultra gory but
while the original won a decent measure
of critical plaudits chapter 2 was
largely felt to be a rehash and one that
looked especially mediocre coming on the
heels of the certified Fresh The
Conjuring which was also directed by
James Juan and scripted by Lee 1l and
was released just two months before
Insidious Chapter 2 is rotten at 38 on
the Tomato Meter with 130 reviews and it
has a 57 audience score and just for
comparison Insidious from 2010 is fresh
at 66 percent insidious chapter 3 from
2015 is rotten at 57 and Insidious the
last key from 2018 is rotten at 33 and
if you can't get enough James Juan Lee
1l talk we covered saw on a previous
podcast so what did the critics have to
say in a rotten review Jeanette katzylus
of the New York Times wrote a mess from
start to finish though judging by the
ending this story won't be over anytime
soon Insidious Chapter 2 is the kind of
lazy half-hearted product that gives
scary movies a bad name however in a
fresh review Michael Phillips at the
Chicago Tribune wrote Juan is getting
better and better at figuring out what
to do with the camera and maneuvering
actors within a Shot For maximum
suspense while letting his design
collaborators do the rest the Rotten
Tomatoes critics consensus reads
Insidious Chapter 2 is decidedly short
on the tension and surprises that made
its predecessor so chilling so that's
Insidious chapter 2. let's kick it back
to Jacqueline and Mark and their line of
work things tend to happen when it gets
dark back to you folks his taglines are
getting so good he's like I love them
like it's just like give the trick cut
the check give the trailer that right
there is Tim it's amazing all right
let's go ahead and break down a little
bit more with Insidious Chapter 2 in our
movie talk section
[Music]
I want to start here because it's so
interesting we talk about Lee wano and
James Wan but also now Blum house
because for folks that don't know
they've sort of like partnered together
they're going to be doing this huge new
Venture and this was really like the
early days of like Plum House this is
not too far after Paranormal Activity
but this is before we get to something
like get out which you could say was
like the maturation of that studio Joe
what is sort of your feelings about Blum
House and particularly what Jason blum's
been able to sort of do with horror over
the past 10 years 15 years yeah I mean
you could arguably say that they've
revolutionized Horrors maybe a very
dramatic turn but they've really
introduced a lot of new horror to the
mainstream culture with you know
Paranormal Activity was a big Turning
Point taking a movie with a micro budget
and then for Blum to take a chance on it
and then tell people let's watch this
movie and put it out for the world it
becomes a huge hit a franchise within
its own
and now they've kind of evolved so much
they you know one Academy an award with
get out and now they're just producing
you know they did Halloween's they're
doing so much now
um you know blumhouse the reinfiguration
of horror lasts 10 years you could put
say plum house is a large part of that
and I think that it's exciting for
horror fans for the next you know the
future with Juan and wanel
um Blum has done a lot and I think you
know horror fans are really grateful for
that do you have a favorite like deep
cut blumhouse movie because they do more
than just horror that's what I love when
they like come and pull something out of
like out of whack I have a I love those
yeah and I just love the model that they
have where it's like we're gonna make
quality Cinema on a budget and we're
gonna put it out and people get excited
to see these movies in a movie theater
like I love when when something comes
out and it feels like an event and you
want to see this kind of stuff opening
night even if it's not the best movie
which Insidious Chapter 2 isn't or the
best franchise which I think Insidious
is in terms of horror but you J you love
that feeling of being in a pack theater
yeah on opening weekend and seeing that
stuff where you get scared and then you
laugh at how scared everybody got and
then you get scared again because that
was just a cat it wasn't the real scare
there's something else behind the door
but in terms of like like I think the
Benchmark for these and I'll go back to
one of the producers of this movie Oren
Pelley who who kind of like like just
brought Paranormal Activity talk about
making a movie on a shoestring budget I
still love pa3 the most because the
oscillating fan trick yeah it's just so
well done but then you also take
Insidious and separating the war from
The Conjuring is something that we may
not have to do much longer because
there's there's rumors that maybe there
can be some sort of crossover or maybe a
crossover the cities in Sinister I I'm
not sure how you want to take it but the
Patrick Wilson effect in all these
movies and and it's it's even tougher to
separate the beginning of this movie
because the first name you hear I think
is Lorraine and you're like rainbow
foreign Patrick Wilson's here but it's
very different Patrick Wilson in these
movies than you would get in the
conjuring conjuring came out in 2013 I
want to say yeah and so Insidious it
really gets uh gets that going is when
they start doing the conjuring that's
when James 1 becomes James Wong yeah and
it's just it's new fresh fun franchises
where you're not trying to reinvent
again Nightmare on Elm Street or Friday
the 13th or even Halloween these these
classic ones from our Collective Youth
it's new stuff and maybe it's starting
to feel a little repetitive now because
we've had so many country movies and we
have a new Insidious movie coming out in
July 7th but I still like that they can
play with the lore in ways that I don't
think those sort of Father Figure
franchises can anymore I mean I I think
any time you're getting into your fifth
fifth and sixth chapter you're gonna
have a chart time making folks feel like
this is going to be new I mean this is
what 20 movies deep in the sort of lore
of all three including Sinister I don't
even know where you put stuff like the
nun but it's also part of that sort of
conjuring version I forgot there were
three Annabelle movies you know I mean
like you're you're getting pretty deep
um I always like remind finding folks
about this one Jason Blum and blumhouse
also produce Whiplash yeah the Jamie hsl
movie I just like that one as like a
deep cut I I think look I I did not I
was not about it this was back when I
didn't watch horror movies yeah you
weren't always a hard movie yeah I was
not and it wasn't against horror movies
I enjoyed horror movies I had too much
trauma and fear to watch them without
worried about like sleeplessness and
this movie I will say had a little bit
of that because then I had to go back
and watch like Insidious chapter one and
like just some of the scares in these
are just like they're not fun like I
have a piano in my house
for you in my house so this was maybe
not the movie for me to watch at nine
o'clock at night actually let me set the
scene for me watching this movie last
night it was great so I was 500 pages
deep on this like incredible Mafia
romance novel I mean this guy was
amazing your romance novels have moved
on to from from the sports locker room
into the sorted time oh my God it was so
great it was uh just so explicitly awful
it was amazing 365 days doesn't have
anything on this book and so then I was
like oh it's like nine o'clock and it's
dark I need to go watch the Insidious
movie for tomorrow because I know I've
forgotten it and that was just too big
of a switch like that was just like too
big of a switch to go from like Raffia
romance to like let me scare you with
the ghost people and like creepy Patrick
Wilson I was so freaked out I was like
not about it it like creeped me out
extra it's a violent turn
um I I do say that that I think that
when you're watching when you're talking
like to one of your friends and they get
scared watching a movie it makes it more
entertaining for you so like what you
went through actually makes Joe and I
probably appreciate the movie oh my God
because we know that it affected you
that way I grew up in a house that had a
piano and a grandfather clock that would
go off at like random times and again
this is all in the landscape of
Williamsburg Virginia
and so you would and usually was just
like the cats jumping on the piano but
you just never know and Molly the Wonder
Dog is older now so she's she's not no
longer a guard dog she's kind of like my
nap buddy and so if I get up in the
middle of the night to get some water or
something like I'm gonna see that woman
in black because I just watched this
movie like I'll invent ways and I'm
coming off of uh Brian uh Perez our
producer's wedding in Catalina Island
which I didn't realize is haunted as
hell right entire island is a green door
apparently there's a theater that's like
one of these green doors without getting
too much into that not a red door but a
green door do you want to like a second
life is like one of those comedian like
Ghost Hunters because you were freaking
me out I would never trade stand up for
anything but if I had to turn my
stand-up card in for something
I don't I get really scared and that's
why I love these movies it's it's that
classic attraction like Joe your hat
says watch more horror movies right yeah
I I I've never been able to articulate
why I love watching them so much because
like they do affect me yeah people
always think if you love horror movies
that you're not scared by them and it's
like no it's the exact opposite I don't
know why I continue to do this to myself
but I still enjoy watching it because I
know it is going to keep me up at night
I mean I will say this overall obviously
you're a pretty big whorehead like rank
this sort of like within this James one
like where you put the franchises
because it's really even silly to say
the movies at this point because there's
too many of them we'd spend 20 minutes
like on all of it but like where do you
put Insidious as it relates to like The
Conjuring I mean you could even say the
Aquaman James Juan Universe uh Sinister
um yeah Furious 7.
emotional movie the most movie um that's
true that is true malignant is is for me
top two year one I'm a malignant Dan I
will die on The Hill from malignant so
I'm malignant number one then I would go
maybe I'd go play the saw franchise okay
then The Conjuring and then Insidious
now now it's important to know I like
ncs1 a lot big fan of Insidious one two
three four uh we'll talk about those
later I'm sure but you know covered for
like I covered four for us here I
remember that was like very early days
of me here and like I'll I'll have fond
memories of that because I was like oh
they're sending me to see a movie and
then I saw that one well and it's funny
though like now it's like if a franchise
needs to take a break and like sit on
the bench for a little bit I feel like
Insidious has done its time on the bench
and now we'll get that door it's like
ready to come roaring back and and
what's interesting about us covering
this particular movie I didn't realize
this until this morning is it the red
door is the direct sequel to Insidious
two so I guess like what was your
biggest issue with Insidious 2
um that like because like you you like
won a lot yeah and then what did what
did two lack or did it just take a
different direction than you wanted so I
think interesting enough what you like
about it is what I'm not sure if I'm a
fan of because I like the further I I
like investigating more yeah although
the first one I think is so interesting
because it is you're on the foundation
it's a classic haunted story this
family's haunted but it does take this
weird turn that very few haunted stories
take and that is oh your son isn't
really possessed he is possessed but not
really he's actually lost in the further
because he can astral project his body
out of his physical body like I don't
know a very little few horror movies in
the past have actually taken that route
which I think is very interesting
Insidious 2 kind of takes that a step
further and says well let's uh throw
some uh time traveling nonsense into the
further now when you're in the astral
world and the further you can visit
yourself as a young in and and kind of
figure out some Mysteries there I think
it goes a little too convoluted and at
that point I just kind of I kind of lose
I mean believability is is already out
the window that could have been why I
appreciated Insidious Chapter 2 more
than you is because I was feeling
convoluted and I'm a dummy everybody
like like you know I never know who the
Killer is like I'm not a smart man but
when I watch Insidious in chapter two I
was like getting a little okay wait so
we can do what in the further and we
can't do other things but then when it
wrapped it all up with that sort of time
travel element and it tied it back it
was a call back instead of terms into
the opening scene and it's like oh now I
see what that kid was doing because he
was actually trying to help his old
herself I thought that was kind of like
a nice
story The Haunting was himself off like
he was literally haunting himself had
like that sort of uh with the sort of
banging I thought that was cool with it
I think it's more interesting to look at
James Juan and Lee wanell because this
is also them coming back together kind
of with Patrick Wilson directing this
new one with the story by Lee wano with
a different scriptwriter because I do
believe on that first one that was just
Lee's screenplay and story and James's
Direction and that was the best
combination because as James no offense
I think got more involved in the
screenwriting I think that's where we
were married to shots over story
development like if you really look at
this one the reason why he didn't take
as much time to carry through some of
these story beats to make the audience
stay with it and it seemed like he gets
married to like oh I gotta get another
scene like the jump scare in the kitchen
from the first one we've got to have
this one that's just as like important
and a lot of that stuff felt forced and
yes I do not like the two sidekick dudes
they they annoy me Jason Tucker I don't
like them they annoy me I feel like they
were forced into parts of this movie
I like them by the time we get to later
installments like they grow on me a lot
but like this one I just felt like they
were just like Ugh it was just like Ugh
that scene and Silence of the Lambs with
her and the two dudes like just played
out for way longer than it needed to be
I'll tell you why I like Bryson Tucker
and and that's we went out and Angus
Samson yeah I mean I don't like again
I'm not like hating on Lee's performance
I just don't like the what the
characters
yeah yeah I love that they are comedic
relief that still serves a purpose
because they're necessary in the movie
because they are these paranormal sort
of investigative types but I think I I
love the the sort of roller coaster ride
that this movie takes you on emotionally
because you do have those levity
um you know spurts what about them
they're cracking a joke and I think it
makes the next scare pay off a little
more because they sort of keep you off
balance they they keep you their humor
keeps you relaxed in a way where you're
laughing and you feel safe but then in
the back your mind you know there's
something scary coming around that door
the big disappointment with me is that
we sort of meet the big bad or what we
even though there's a twist with this
woman actually being like this creepy
dude I still miss the Darth Maul from
the first one yeah I'm kind of waiting
for that demon to show up like where
where's mom you know where's the guy and
and you never get that and so that's why
I think I was left down the cold but I
think Tucker inspect really came to play
even more in this one than they did in
the first one I think they should have
been peppered in less that's what I mean
like just a little bit less like I felt
they over egged their pudding for the
reason that you're talking about I think
it's a cheap way to undo the tension to
take the to take the audience off guard
and they they played the card too many
times Joe break this tie you know I I
sit here kind of like nodding to both
you guys like who am I going to agree
with here I like specs and Tucker do I
think they're in it a little too much a
little too Goofy for this movie yeah I
think so there's a scene where they like
are they have to do this uh what they
call it bear ninja Hunter yeah it's like
rock paper scissors I love that and it's
like
let's just get into the scariness let's
build that tension uh when they have to
play this game even at the very end and
when like the big climactic moment
happens you get I think like Tucker
jumps out randomly to like oh I'm gonna
fight you guys but it's all over
a little too much and the writer I mean
he wrote it for himself there's also a
little bit of self-serving here you know
what I mean like this is Lee literally
making himself have more parts in his
own movie like do you think you feel
like Crystal did a little bit and I love
Billy Crystal but I remember my aunt
complaining about Billy Crystal movies
like look I like Billy Crystal he's
great but it seems like he gives himself
all the best lives and I remember
thinking like in my like like you know
little uh you know comedian zygote brain
I remember thinking well that's what I
would do if I wrote about it I would
just give myself this is a connection
here it's because you're a comedian
about forget Paris what did he write I
honestly think it was forget Paris oh my
God I think that it was either that
awake City Slickers one or two but I
think it's only stickers two Heroes he's
great I love Billy Crystal and I love
Tucker and specs um but also that that
jumps that the the relief of the scare
at the end right where I'm still not
sure if we should trust Patrick Wilson
because Patrick Wilson is a guy and he's
a great lead for this movie because he
is the guy who can go insane he can go
uh The Shining Jack Torrance level but
unlike what happens with that character
and his wife played by Shelley Duvall
this one he snaps out of it and he's
back to his normal self and within
seconds the kids are like oh we love you
Dad and it takes roseburn a little bit
longer it takes her it takes her to hang
a minute and then she gets back in there
and I still am not trusting what's
happening but then Angus Samson breaks
through with the joke and I'm like okay
now we can feel peace for for the moment
for this scene but anytime there's a
laugh near the end of a horror movie
especially nowadays I know there's one
more page we gotta read and that's what
I did appreciate about the ending of
Insidious because that first one was
such a great Cliffhanger and Insidious 2
the the Cliffhanger scene nowhere near
as powerful as that first Insidious but
now we do find that it does set some
stuff up for the red door and so I think
more in retrospect I might be more
forgiving to this movie because I know
so it was playing the long game I mean
was it or did they have to go back and
rewrite it because I'm like I like to
think they thought this all the way
through I'd like to think that me too
I'm not saying they did there's some
batons they dropped along the way along
the series that like lead me to think
that um whether or not the other reason
why I feel good about it is for as much
as Patrick Wilson is just like a great
actor in this and he is doing such good
work there's some just absolutely cringy
acting moments in this movie like just
Sequoia level wooden and the kid is not
far from it like I'm sorry the kids Ty
Simpkins my boy at that age he was not
from Jurassic world I know he gets
better he does get better he's not great
in the beginning of this he's doing a
little bit much it's a bit cheesy well
if you're talking about acting presences
the one that I missed in this one Joe
that that she shows up eventually but I
feel like Lynn Shay is the least I
really miss her fingerprints yeah no pun
intended all over this movie as opposed
to her just being a corpse in the first
scene and then showing up in the further
I think way too late in the movie that
might be my biggest bone to pick with
this move is that like she is just so
good at building this world in the first
one and we have this feeling as an
audience right from the start of the
film that we're gonna get to meet her
again and her dead on the chair is not
the end of her care character's journey
and it just took way too long to get
there for me yeah and also like the fact
that they said they had to call her back
I thought that was so cute like oh no
I'm in the happy place sweetie I'm not
here with all of them yeah it almost
feels like they've noticed that as well
because she becomes a bigger presence in
the third one and the fourth I mean the
fourth it's her movie yeah it's almost
like they realized oh she is kind of
like the anchor to these horror movies
this or this Insidious stories and so
they do make her more of a focus in the
third one and the fourth one so yeah it
kind of sucks we don't get to see a lot
of her in this one and when we do she's
in the further kind of leading the way
but that's like halfway through the
movie you know what really impressed me
though is the the younger version of
Elise oh and I forget the actresses the
flashback oh yeah he is tremendous and I
think it was Lynn shade doing the voice
I I can't confirm that but it's it
sounded so much like Lynn Shay either
that woman has a dead on Lynn Shay
impression or it was Lynn doing the
voiceover and it matches so well and
then I really believed that was the
younger version of that character so I
thought that was pretty cool and then as
far as like younger versions of people
showing up the very end we get a very
young Jenna Ortega being knighted into
the world of horror movies and now she's
a huge success uh thanks in part to the
screen franchise and she was good in it
so I'm not against child actor I look Ty
got so much better especially by the
time the series got on but he this was
acting he was the kid that got kidnapped
and basically laid there in the first
movie didn't have as much going on he
was the the thing they were trying to
get back this one I think it was a bit
of stress well I'm sorry not everyone is
your nephew Timothy oh my God stop Hey
listen that 38 didn't come from just the
plot okay I mean at least Ty Simpkins
gets sunscreen time they have another
brother yeah that's true Foster is
another they forget about that brother
all the time
or the other the other brother yeah this
one he's like he appears for a couple
seconds he talks on like the can radio
and then he's gone you want to cool gag
though and I love the can radio in this
movie yeah I love where they their
brothers and they sleep across the room
from each other and they like play games
and like they have Forts and stuff they
have that cam radio kind of talking
mechanism and then he picks it up and
it's not Foster and it starts leading
into the closet oh that's a good one
yeah it seems like they're bringing that
back in the new movie it'll be
interesting to see who because the third
Insidious was actually the one where I
think they started to like it that was
the one where it got into the 50 range
so even though it wasn't really well
received comparatively to this one they
they sort of like got it back but I
don't want to leave this though remember
this was the found footage era I
specifically love that that was
something that they did give them
something to do in this one this idea of
like looking at found footage as a way
to sort of like Stitch up the story I
didn't think that was kind of cool and
the way that they switch up the shots I
thought it was interesting the way Juan
directed this movie where you know you
may not love the characters of Tucker
and specs but the fact that when we're
following them it is found footage and
you're actually sometimes looking in
you're Blair witching yes the movie and
I thought that that really worked as
sort of a switch up for the more
stationary shots that you get of the
family and Rose Byrne walking around the
house and just losing your mind like if
I'm roseburn in this movie I'm out I'm
out one of my kids isn't maybe I'll take
Foster and he'll be fine yeah I'm done
with this family after hearing how far
back the floor goes get me the hell out
of there yeah Patrick you get you get
you get the the haunted kid and I'll
take the kid who has nothing to do with
sleep
I have more to do in sleep by the time
we get to the other one um I will say
this is sort of like to sum it up was
there one moment that you found to be
the scariest for this one all together
or was there anything that you're sort
of like okay if you're gonna do chapter
two because I have mine that that sort
of like uh scene with the the guy behind
the the whatever you call it the clear
glass where the bodies go that that one
got me but what about you well it's
interesting because I think someone said
earlier that they thought this one was
less scary than the first one I thought
it was maybe more scary but with just
more jump scares now naturally I jump
more maybe the stairs aren't as uh
genuine or as powerful but uh for
Insidious chapter two there were a
couple that got me there was one where
Rose Byrne thinks she's going crazy
she's kind of walking around the house
uh Furniture randomly flies sometimes
and then the camera does this cool trick
where it turns and then the woman is
there and it slaps roseburn and she like
it's like knocked out that was pretty
scary but I think the one that a lot of
people will say is like the moment is
probably
there's a bunch of people on under
sheets and they like lift the sheets up
and then one of them is uh is the lady
and she like reaches at them trying to
choke uh I don't know who it is not
Patrick will this is Patrick Wilson or
is it Carl I don't remember who it is it
maybe Carl actually trying to choke
somebody very scary I thought that part
was really scary I also love the uh the
loud music from the from the children's
toys yeah that would turn off oh yeah
yeah that's sort of like you know the
proverbial cat making the oh it's just
the cat this one it's like the the toys
turning on and off I thought just the
sound effect of that it's one of those
great again opening weekend scares and
everybody laughs because we were a bunch
of adults that paid to see this movie
and we just got frightened by a kid's
toy yeah and I will say I don't know if
the piano would have been as scary in
the theater but it definitely freaked me
out last night having a literal grand
piano in my house and it was just like
fun watching at home for that reason
though yeah I don't know about it that
adds to the to the general scares I want
to just make sure we ask this one as far
as what we're excited for the red door
knowing it's a sequel to this where do
you think they're maybe gonna go with
the Joe or where do you hope they go
with it they I hope they bring back the
red face demon that's and it feels like
that's the direction they're going it's
just so strange to me to introduce such
a scary character in the very first film
and kind of a big pop culture hit I mean
people recognize that person as either
the Darth Maul villain from Insidious
but people know that person they know
the jump scare the very iconic jump
scare in the kitchen with him appearing
behind Patrick Wilson everybody knows
that so I hope the red door brings him
back I want to get more of him I was sad
we didn't see him in chapter two bring
back him bring back the music that weird
uh Tiptoe Through the Tulip song that
was played a lot during the first movie
I want to hear that again it's a very
creepy like Happy song I want to see
that in the red door I have somehow
avoided any promotional material for the
red door
so because like I know Joe you're not a
huge trailer
Enthusiast especially like trailer two
and three and four it's like I've seen
enough you already got my money I'm
gonna go see the movie I haven't seen a
trailer for this so I don't know if they
hint at Darth Maul coming back but if
you give me that guy again at last we
will reveal ourselves to the Jedi at
last we will have Revenge
I just remembered something too I
actually and this is like kind of name
dropping but not really uh just because
I'm a moderator I announced this project
at Blum Fest yeah blumfest 2000 it was
during the pandemic so it had to be like
2020 maybe blumfest 2020 was then when
this was announced and I announced it
with like Patrick and them coming back
thanks Jason for the gig it was fun yeah
as As Nice of a little career bump as
that might have been for you I think it
only furthers your fear of your own
grand piano because you start talking
about this stuff Jacqueline and it just
gets its hooks India and I'm sorry that
grand piano it may be too late already
it's not that it's like the grand piano
would haunt you it's just like you know
I listen to a lot of instrumental music
and so whenever you just start thinking
about like scores and pianos and things
and then you just start thinking about
this movie it's just I don't need those
two things to meld have you ever heard
like the piano like play itself no but
it does sometimes settle and it'll do
like a thing oh
scales pretty much every other day and
so like yeah do you want me and Joe to
come to your place and Tucker inspects
it no I think I'm fine the person that
lives in my house he he handled this
okay well we are playing Hunter ninja
bear actually Hunter ninja bear perfect
I don't know exactly who wins like who
beats the ninja who beats the hunter
well that's why it's funny because like
they're arguing even though they know
there's a clear winner and loser like
rock paper scissors they're arguing that
a bear how does a bear exactly defeat a
ninja every time it's it's beautiful
beautiful why
[Laughter]
if you like them and comedy is one way
to get you to like somebody more if you
like them now you're invested in those
characters and it's scary when they go
down the stairs because now you're
rooting for these people and you love
them you welcome them into your heart
and now they could be terrorized by this
demon are you just mad because I don't
like the comic relief does it hit you in
a place close to your heart you have
spent way too many nights with me on the
common store Patio
I think I understand I apologize I
apologize real quick final thoughts on
Patrick Wilson uh directorial I think
it's debut debut yeah I'm excited I love
horror movies I love a good summertime
Feast July 7th happens to be uh my
birthday when I'm doing my pay-per-view
uh next uh hour special release alive
and well so I will be alive and well
that night hosting that but probably
that Saturday night I'll probably go
check out Insidious The Red Door all
right I I will definitely try but I will
be in Mexico
I'll meet you there I can write that off
as a birthday expense you
uh what about you you're gonna you're
gonna see it oh of course I'm gonna see
it yeah I love Patrick Wilson and I
think giving new directors especially
actors nowadays a chance at horror
debuts really exciting stuff I mean we
saw peel make his debut change the world
with get out I think a lot of directors
especially actor train directors are
looking into horror as a way to make
their debut and I'm excited I love
Patrick Wilson I'm excited and
especially somebody who's like been in
this world it's almost like you've been
a backup quarterback for for you know
five years and now you're ready for your
time to get the starting job he's been
on these kind of sets working with these
directors for so long it's like oh now
let's see what you got I think the other
thing too is like look Krasinski peel
yeah I think hater just came out in an
interview saying he's got an idea for
her oh give me that put that right into
my veins we're gonna I mean look the
last season of Barry was a horror movie
it's like so if that's where he's going
I will be watching though that's going
to be it for us on the movie talk
section we're actually going to rip up
in our mailbox so Brian cue the music
[Music]
all right we have ketchup crew member
Larry H did I miss an episode how has
Constantine from 2005 not been covered
it has been okay if I take two full
episode juice that's what's the must be
done Larry Larry Larry your girl's got
you we've got you we've done Constantine
I feel like I've talked about it too
much but honestly it is the movie I just
I I still think about and now I've heard
that they're maybe going to shove the
Keanu Reeves one like Oh you mean
because they were going to make a sequel
yeah and now it's maybe on the back
burner I don't know if if this Bros has
that kind of money anymore oh honey I'm
sorry it's 46 rotten the audience agrees
with you that it's fresh 72 so Larry
that was on episode 46 back in July of
2021 we were all so young uh Joe we know
your feelings on Paddington too and it's
greatness is there a movie that is
rotten that you feel was maligned along
the same level as as Jacqueline feels
for Constantine or I may feel for Young
Guns too no for Young Guns too that's
yours fantastic movie we've covered that
too as well there's a lot um there's a
lot I would say uh probably the leader
of the bunch was
let's go with Tron legacy it is my okay
my ultimate pick for the movie that has
a iran-ish score I think it's it's not
like it's like teetering rotten Headland
uh Garrett Hedland Joseph Kaczynski you
know billionaire filmmaker who made a
billion dollars off topka Maverick uh a
old and young Jeff Bridges
yeah Olivia Wilde yeah no it was it was
a fun ride I love when he walks into the
arcade and journey starts cranking like
you got my money already
um it just it's weird that he goes into
this new world and I've complained about
it before and he starts playing the
sport for the first time and he's
immediately LeBron James well I mean
that's the way it's supposed to be
you're supposed to be inside and we saw
him on a motorcycle earlier not jumping
off freeway then that's fair okay
clearly's athletic plus that Daft Punk
soundtrack is I was just saying I can
get behind you on the soundtrack I that
movie no
the brightness of that movie really
messes with my eyes eyesight I wonder if
we'll get a new Tron or a new
Constantine more new Young Guns first
honestly I would bet on Young Guns
they're working on it Tron is already in
the pipeline it isn't okay I think Joe's
got the inside track if you know about
it you wouldn't know about it before you
get out of here please let folks know
where they can find you and if you could
give us a TV or movie recommendation sir
okay you can find me on on The Tick Tock
Instagram and Twitter at Cinema show I
do a lot of reviews lists rankings uh
rants on there as well uh my podcast
how's Cinema we talk about movies every
week as well
um and the last recommendation a movie
recommendation
uh well I don't want to recommend across
spider verse it feels like everybody has
saw that movie already so uh dude that
movie's so good that's a very good movie
oh yeah no I I saw it uh over the
weekend that's so goddamn very good
movie I mean if you haven't seen it
already go watch it that's a big obvious
recommendation but if you have seen it
uh and you want to watch something new
go watch past lives which came out yeah
this past week as well oh okay that
movie was a game changer for me done and
done on the docket that's uh that's a
big Awards play I do know that yeah what
up a24 uh that is gonna be it for us
this week if you want to be like Larry
you know you did miss an episode Larry
but it's okay
it's okay it just it hurts we could
cover it again but we don't need to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com please let us know
what you think we should be covering and
wherever you're listening to this please
rate review And subscribe and we will
see you guys next because Mr Tom Cruise
is back he's running he's coming into
theaters so we're talking what sir oh my
God his hair is so good in Mission
Impossible too I
I've wanted many different hairstyles in
my life haven't been able to pull most
of them off but my when he's climbing
the rock at the beginning of Mission
Impossible 2 that's just that is just
sex appeal that is sexy yeah I am in
John Woo doing it Mission Impossible too
baby let's do Grace got this thing all I
think about is Ben Stiller hosting the
TV movie awards impersonating him now
like like they do that thing and I'm
like that is the thing it is like such a
thing anyway but uh we will be back for
that one next week I'm sorry I'm just
thinking of that yeah it's just it's so
bad way Mission Impossible 2 next week
Joe thank you so much for joining us for
Brian Remsen Mr Mark Ellis and myself
we'll see y'all next week on Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong bye y'all
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]